[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france
au sommaire aujourd'hui l'irak prise en
étau entre ces deux puissantes
partenaires les états unis et les rangs
ce pays cherche de plus en plus à
diversifier ses alliances dans la région
et ce sur fond de turbulences internes
alors à quoi ressemble la vie politique
en irak aujourd'hui
depuis fin décembre 2020 de nouvelles
manifestations antigouvernementales sont
organisées dans plusieurs villes
irakiennes
en cause la décision de la banque
centrale de dévaluer le dinars irakiens
de près de 25% par rapport au dollar
américain
le gouvernement affirme ne pas avoir
d'autres solutions face à la forte crise
économique que traverse le pays à
l'international bagdad et contre un
dossier entre washington et téhéran
à peine entré en fonction le premier
ministre irakien moustapha al kadhim y
seront en iran pour sa première visite à
l'étranger
quelques semaines plus tard al kadhim y
est accueilli à la maison blanche où il
mène des négociations avec donald trump
nombre d'accords sont conclus à l'issue
de la visite
parallèlement le gouvernement d' al qadi
me cherche à diversifier ses partenaires
dans la région
ils se rapprochent notamment des états
du golfe et renforce les liens avec la
france
al kadhim il se dit aussi favorable à la
coopération avec moscou qui a des
propositions dans le domaine militaire
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur la mosaïque est non
confessionnelle qui influencent le
système politique de l'irak
c'est le blitz pays très majoritairement
musulman l'irak compte 60 à 65% de shit
et 32 à 37 % de musulmans sunnites sur
le plan ethnique les arabes représentent
la majorité absolue les kurdes et les
turkmènes quant à eux sont largement de
confession sunnite
alors qu'à l'époque de saddam hussein
les sunnites dominé la vie politique
irakienne depuis 2005 un système de
partage de pouvoir et mis en place la
fonction présidentielle est donc
toujours attribué un kurde celle de
premier ministre à un arabe chiite est
celle du président du parlement
un arabe sunnite le parlement irakien
lui est dominée par les chiites qui
prône une coopération étroite avec les
rangs il occupe 187 sièges sur 329 les
arabes sunnites eux dispose de 70
députés les kurdes de 58 et les
turkmènes de 4 ces derniers sont plutôt
favorables à l'amitié avec washington au
sein du gouvernement
le rapport de forces est similaire douze
ministres son shit 6 sunnites et 3
kurdes en irak les tensions ne
s'apaisent pas depuis le mois de
décembre la contestation populaire prend
de l'ampleur pour dénoncer les mesures
d'austérité imposées par les autorités
irakiennes celle ci disent ne pas avoir
d'autres solutions face à la profonde
crise économique et sociale la situation
sécuritaire sans pire elle aussi
profitant du confinement
les djihadistes de l'état islamique
lance les unes après les autres des
attaques contre les militaires et civils
irakiens à l'international bagdad reste
coincé entre les usa et les rangs dès sa
prise de pouvoir en mai 2001 le premier
ministre moustapha al kadhim y endosse
le rôle d'équilibristes ils seront en
visite en iran un accord est conclu pour
développer les relations bilatérales
ensuite
vient la rencontre avec donald trump à
la maison blanche les avancées sont
nombreuses là aussi washington exemple
temporairement l'irak des sanctions anti
iranienne et promet de fermer les yeux
sur l'achat des hydrocarbures auprès de
téhéran trempe promet aussi de retirer
une partie des forces américaines du sol
irakien
en même temps al kadhim i saw tourne
aussi vers d'autres partenaires
l'international il se rapproche ainsi de
ryad et un thème un dialogue avec paris
et moscou
quels avantages ses diversifications
diplomatique apporte-t-elle à l'irak
comment al kadhim il réussit il a jonglé
entre l'amitié de washington et la
coopération avec téhéran
quelle est l'ampleur de la crise
économique et social en cours dans le
pays pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons meriam benraad docteur en
sciences politiques de l'institut
d'études politiques de paris yves adam
meinrad bonjour bonjour
tout d'abord pourquoi selon vous les rec
n'at-il jamais réussi à se remettre sur
pied après l'intervention des états unis
et de leurs alliés en 2003 pas pour
plusieurs raisons la première ça a été
le caractère tout à fait catastrophique
désastreux de cette intervention
militaire américaine qui a été d'une
part une intervention unilatérale contre
l'avis de la communauté internationale
qui n'était pas une intervention
préparée qui aboutit en l'espace de
quelques semaines au printemps 2003 à
l'effondrement de l'état irakien
l'effondrement de la sécurité de l'ordre
public des institutions qui en fait
façonner une insurrection armée de long
terme dont un groupe comme l'état
islamique est issu notamment mais pas
seulement on a aussi beaucoup de groupes
paramilitaires qui aujourd'hui au
concurrence directement les teints
l'autorité la souveraineté de l'état
central et les élites irakienne qui
étaient majoritairement issus de
l'ancienne opposition au régime bassiste
ont été des autorités à la merci
finalement de l'occupant étranger qui
n'ont jamais eu de marge de manoeuvre
propre
en termes de calendrier politique en
termes aussi comme je les dis de
décisions souveraines
dans le pays et aujourd'hui on voit bien
que l'irak en paye le prix lourd puisque
on a en délabrement massif une société
complètement fragmenté une nation qui
n'existe quasiment même plus et puis
surtout à cela s'ajoute aujourd'hui la
crise sanitaire du coffee 19 qui en fait
fait de cet état de délabrement un état
je dirais de de désespérance totale
puisque par ailleurs on n'a même pas de
services de santé à la hauteur de
l'enjeu
aujourd'hui on voit bien que academy
essayer de balancer entre ces deux
partenaires principaux les états unis et
l'iran pensez vous que ce soit un choix
judicieux pour l'irak
oui alors il ya cet exercice un peu
d'équilibriste entre entre les états
unis et l'iran qui sont les deux
principaux acteurs en fait en irak
depuis 2003 puisque en 2003
l'intervention américaine elle aboutit
aussi à une emprise de plus en plus
forte de la part de l'iran sur le pays
parce que l'iran possède des relais
d'influencé à la fois politique
économique identitaire aussi très fort
très puissants notamment dans le sud
irakien qui vont se généraliser
finalement après 2003 maintenant il faut
quand même être très très réaliste
l'acteur aujourd'hui le plus influencé
l'iran les etats-unis ont perdu leur
marge de manoeuvre du fait de cette
occupation désastreuse je rappelle
qu'ils ont quitté le pays une première
fin 2011
finalement après un fiasco militaire
totale ils se sont réengagés
partiellement contre l'état islamique en
2014 mais sans ambition doré engagement
massif donc aujourd'hui l'iran est
plutôt à mon avis à la merci le l'irak
pardon est plutôt à la merci de l'iran
quand bien même il est vrai qu'il ya un
sentiment anti iraniens très fort parce
que les irakiens veulent recouvrer leur
souveraineté
ce à quoi l'iran s'oppose pour des
raisons géostratégiques et aussi parce
que l'irak c'est l'ancien ennemi aux
régionales de l'iran ne l'oublions pas
donc les iraniens n'ont aucun intérêt à
voir l'irak se relever
sur le plan du plan stratégique mais
c'est ce qui explique aussi pourquoi
l'irak se tourner vers de nouveaux
partenaires parce qu'on parle de l'iran
des etats-unis
mais je rappelle qu'il ya quand même de
plus en plus de rapprochement de contrat
par exemple avec des pays comme la
russie ou la chine
parce que et les européens aussi en
partie parce que les irakiens ont bien
compris qu'ils ont plutôt intérêt à
diversifier leur alliance car reposer
uniquement sur l'iran ou les états unis
merci beaucoup au mad amènera nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons à la
fin de cette émission pour plus de
détails sur la question merci encore
l'irak traverse une nouvelle période de
turbulences depuis fin décembre des
centaines d'irakiens descendent dans les
rues de plusieurs villes pour protester
contre les mesures d'austérité imposées
par les autorités
parmi elles la dévaluation du dinar
irakien de près de 25% par rapport au
dollar américain une première depuis 50
ans les manifestants dénoncent un coup
sévère porté à leur pouvoir d'achat et
exhorte le gouvernement à revoir sa
décision
pourtant le premier ministre affirme ne
pas avoir d'autre solution depuis 2003
nous souffrons à cause de notre mauvais
gouvernement qui menace d'effondrement
complet le système politique et social
soit le système s'effondre et sombre
dans le chaos total
soit nous allons subir une césarienne en
vue d'une remise en état des changements
de taille s'annonce aussi au sein du
système politique irakien juste après sa
prise de fonction en mai 2020 moustapha
al qadi me promet la tenue des élections
législatives anticipées le 6 juin 2021
une décision sensée avant tout calmer le
mouvement de contestation qui secoue le
pays depuis des mois tout commence début
octobre 2019 lorsqu'une partie de la
population irakienne descendent dans la
rue pour protester contre la corruption
le chômage et l'état désastreux des
services publics dans le pays ces
exigences
un renouvellement complet de la classe
politique et des réformes économiques
très vite la contestation se répand dans
toutes les régions en réponse le
gouvernement déploie les forces de
l'ordre afin de disperser les
manifestants
le bilan est lourd en
quelques mois d'émeutes sans 150
personnes sont tuées et trente mille
sont blessés cette révolte sans
précédent contre un le premier ministre
de l'époque
adel abdel mahdi a démissionné en
novembre 2019 en février 2020 avec
l'approbation du parlement mohamed
toufik allaoui lui succède choisi
principalement par les chiites il est
mal acceptée par le reste de la
population
c'est donc une nouvelle figure adnane
orfi qui prend la relève mais seulement
pour une très courte durée ce n'est
qu'en avril que le compromis finalement
atteint autour de la figure d' al kadhim
fin négociateur il réussit à obtenir le
soutien de la quasi totalité des
formations politiques du parlement
après plusieurs mois de vacance du
pouvoir le nouveau premier ministre
hérite d'une situation économique et
sociale catastrophique la banque
mondiale parle de la pire crise depuis
2003 le pib se contracte de 9 7% l'année
dernière alors que le déficit budgétaire
se creuse jusqu'à 29 % du pib le taux de
pauvreté lui passe de 20% à 31 7% en
2020 la corruption endémique paralyse le
fonctionnement des institutions de
l'état
l'irak fait partie des 20 pays les plus
corrompus du monde selon transparency
international le chômage est un autre
défi de taille
plus d'un quart des jeunes sont à la
recherche d'un emploi l'autre
conséquence de ce chaos et la crise
sécuritaire
profitant de la pandémie du comique 19
et d'un affaiblissement des autorités
irakiennes
l'état islamique semble renaître de ses
cendres
durant les trois premiers mois de 2000
vin qu'ils ont menée sans 166 attaque ce
qui est nettement supérieur à la même
période en 2010 neuf dans ce contexte se
pose la question de l'efficacité des
troupes américaines censé lutter contre
le terrorisme
mais washington a également un agenda
parallèle dont ils ne se cachent pas
assez surveillé l'iran début 2001
l'armée américaine va jusqu'à assassiner
le général iranien qasem soleimani à
bagdad
c'est là que le parlement irakien dominé
par les musulmans chiites favorable à
léran perd patience
le gouvernement irakien doit s'efforcer
de mettre fin à la présence des troupes
étrangères sur le sol irakien et leur
interdire d'utiliser ses terres son
espace aérien où ses os pour quelques
raisons que ce soit la réponse est
immédiate la maison blanche rejette
toute possibilité du retrait complet de
ses troupes nous avons là une base
aérienne extrêmement cher une
construction qui coûtent des milliards
de dollars
nous partirons pas à moins qu'il ne nous
rembourse nous leur imposons des
sanctions comme ils n'en n'ont jamais vu
auparavant dans les relations
bilatérales le ton change suite à
l'arrivée au pouvoir de mustapha al qadi
me il prône le maintien de la
coopération militaire avec washington
mais se dit quand même opposé à la
présence des forces américaines dans le
pays pour faire entendre sa position
al-qasimi initie en jouant un dialogue
stratégique irako-américain les
résultats se font sentir en septembre
lorsque washington annonce vouloir
réduire de cinq mille deux cents à 3000
ses effectifs en irak
cette entente dur at-elle dans le temps
quel impact la coopération avec
washington at elle sur les relations
irako iranienne comment le premier
ministre al qadi mi temps utile de
diversifier la politique étrangère de
l'iran
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
corruption pauvreté insécurité l'irak se
trouve en proie à une grave crise
économique et sécuritaire
et tout cela sur fond d'une forte
instabilité politique et se poursuit
depuis la proclamation de la république
parlementaire
suite à l'intervention des états unis et
de leurs alliés en irak en 2003 le
président saddam hussein est renversé
pays parmi les plus stables du
moyen-orient l'irak se retrouve plongé
dans le chaos
ces infrastructures sont endommagés le
système politique est complètement
détruit l'opération baptisée liberté
irakienne coûtent la vie à des milliers
d'entre eux les armes de destruction de
masse dont la présence supposée a servi
de prétexte à l'intervention ne sont
jamais découverte
néanmoins un contingent militaire de la
coalition restent sur place
plus encore le pouvoir se trouve entre
les mains de l'administration provisoire
américaine ce n'est qu'après l'adoption
de la constitution provisoire en 2004
que s'effectue le transfert du pouvoir
au gouvernement intérimaire irakien mais
il est dirigée par iyad allawi un homme
politique chiite pro américain en
janvier 2005 les premières élections
législatives sont organisées
ouvrant ainsi la voie à la rédaction
d'une nouvelle constitution
celle ci est adoptée par référendum en
octobre 2005 et proclame l'irak une
république parlementaire de nouvelles
élections ont lieu en décembre
une victoire écrasante et remporté par
l'alliance irakienne unie fier parti
chiite clairement pro iranien il désigne
ibrahim al-jaafari au poste de premier
ministre
les sunnites qui dominaient la scène
politique du pays sous saddam hussein
perdre alors définitivement leur poids
politique résultat les tensions
s'accentuent entre deux groupes
religieux ce qui dégénère en 2006 en
guerre civile faisant plus de 30 mille
victimes parmi la population
ces violences inouïes s'accompagne de
troubles économiques elles jafari quitte
son poste sa place désormais occupée par
nouri al-maliki désigné par l'alliance
irakienne unie fier une fois arrivé au
pouvoir il propose un projet de
réconciliation nationale qui prévoit la
réintégration des soldats et officiers
des forces de saddam hussein
principalement sunnites au sein de
l'armée irakienne petit à petit la
situation se stabilise après l'arrivée
au pouvoir de l'administration obama
la coalition commencent petit à petit à
retirer ses troupes en 2011 les derniers
soldats américains rentrent chez eux
pourtant l'accalmie à une courte durée
depuis 2012 la paix est à nouveau
menacée par le groupe radical de l'état
islamique
le 10 juin 2014 il s'empare de mossoul
la deuxième plus grande ville irakienne
la menace pèse désormais sur la capitale
le gouvernement irakien se voit donc
contraint de demander l'aide des états
unis en même temps l'irak s'enfonce dans
une nouvelle crise politique le premier
ministre du pays
nouri al maliki est farouchement
critiqué par l'opposition voire par des
membres de son propre parti en raison
des lourdes défaites que subit l'irak
sur le champ de bataille
enfin il cède aux pressions et en
septembre 2014
le parlement irakien élit un nouveau
premier ministre
à deir el abbadi sous sa direction
l'armée irakienne soutenue par la
coalition internationale repousse l'état
islamique des alentours de la capitale
et libère plusieurs villes stratégiques
dont mossoul est fin 2017
el abbadi annonce la victoire contre
l'état islamique leur utilité juge est
terminée le parlement demande un
calendrier du retrait des troupes
américaines
pourtant les états unis ne se presse pas
de faire leurs valises
prétextant de la nécessité de continuer
la lutte antiterroriste
en interne la tension connaît un regain
après la tenue des élections
législatives en 2018
plusieurs mois de négociations entre les
principales forces politiques permettent
la désignation d adel abdel mahdi
indépendant au poste de premier ministre
pourtant ce dernier n'arrive pas à
stabiliser le pays qui s'enfonce dans
une crise socio-économique pauvreté
corruption chômage parmi les jeunes
le mécontentement populaire couvre
pendant des mois avant d'exploser en
octobre 2019 des milliers d'irakiens
descendre dans les rues protestant
contre l'inefficacité du gouvernement
sous la pression adel abdel mahdi quitte
le poste de premier ministre
sa position géographique fait de l'irak
un vrai carrefour stratégique du moyen
orient
c'est pourquoi depuis les années 2000 ce
billet est la pierre angulaire de la
stratégie américaine dans la région pour
washington l'irak est le principal avant
poste militaire au moyen orient
c'est le centre de ses opérations contre
les djihadistes et surtout contre des en
plus leur présence en irak permet aux
états unis de veiller sur l'iran et de
contrer son influence croissante
en échange washington armes et entraîne
l'armée irakienne protège ses
institutions fragiles et fournit de
l'aide financière et humanitaire
plus de 70 milliards de dollars depuis
20 ans l'appui américain est essentiel
pour l'irak
tout comme l'alliance qu'il entretient
avec l'iran sur le plan sécuritaire les
milices pro iraniennes sont un appui de
taille de l'armée irakienne face aux
terroristes en plus l'irak dépendent des
exportations iraniennes pour couvrir
près d'un tiers de ses besoins en
énergie
la dépendance est d'ailleurs mutuelle
car l'irak est quasiment le seul client
énergétique de téhéran asphyxiés par les
sanctions
bagdad est aussi un maillon clé de l'arc
chiite zone d' influence iranienne qui
englobe la syrie et le liban l'irak doit
donc naviguer entre les deux feux et se
retrouve souvent en ligne de mire
décembre 2019 washington accusé l'iran
d'avoir frappé sa base militaire en irak
le mois suivant le général iranien
soleymani et tués alors qu'ils se
trouvent en irak
poursuivant cette escalade téhéran
répond en lançant des missiles sur une
base américaine située et le site en
irak
baghdad frôle alors la guerre sur son
territoire s'ensuit un statu quo que
washington et téhéran veulent
apparemment préserver exemple de cette
volonté de paix la nomination d' al qadi
me justement au poste de premier
ministre en mars 2020 selon le middle
east high
c'est le résultat d'un accord secret
entre téhéran et washington
ainsi la maison blanche débloque des
actifs iraniens gelés sous sanction et
en échange
teheran garantie l'appui des partis pro
iranien en irak à la candidature d' al
kadhim réputé pour être proche des
américains al kadhim y naviguent
pourtant habilement entre téhéran et
washington
ainsi en juillet il fait un geste envers
l'iran et s'y rend pour sa toute
première visite à l'étranger
puis vient le ton des états unis qui
accueille al-qasimi en août un test
diplomatique réussi à la demande d'al
kadimi washington prolonger
l'autorisation pour l'irak d'importer de
l'énergie depuis les rangs malgré les
sanctions
en échange al qadhi me promets à
washington la fin de sa dépendance
énergétique à téhéran d'ici cinq ans
cependant le nouveau premier ministre
irakien là vous balancer entre les
intérêts iraniens et américains
c'est pas facile je suis comme un
funambule entre deux grands bâtiments
en plus je dois parcourir cette corde
non pas en marchant mais à vélo chaque
jour je danse avec les serpents mais je
continue de chercher une flûte qui
pourrait les apprivoiser afin d' éviter
l'impasse al qadhi me cherche de
nouveaux alliés en commençant par ses
voisins du moyen-orient premier succès
le rapprochement avec ryad en novembre
l'arabie saoudite et l'irak rouvrir leur
frontière commune fermée depuis trente
ans un pas historique qui débloque les
échanges commerciaux
entre les deux pays parallèlement al
qadi me ranime l'alliance dite du
nouveau le vent entre l'irak l'egypte et
la jordanie un accord économique entre
les trois pays et signer ailleurs dans
la région
layrac conforte aussi ses liens avec le
liban koweït ou encore la turquie
la campagne diplomatique irakiennes
continuent aussi en europe en octobre
al kadhim il part en tournée sur le
vieux continent au programme les visites
en france en allemagne et au royaume uni
l'irakien plaide pour un appui militaire
face aux terroristes et tente de
décrocher des investissements pour
sauver son économie sans grand succès
berlin et londres parle de soutien mais
leur engagement reste modeste
la france elle est plus enthousiaste la
france non seulement coopérera pour vous
aider à chaque fois que nous pouvons le
faire
la france sera à votre soutien pour
justement s'assurer que toute la
communauté internationale puisse suivre
soutenir accompagner et des
investissements défense énergie
éducation la france multiplie des
initiatives pour soutenir bagdad et cela
sur fond de tes engagements progressive
des états unis en irak
néanmoins la france n'est pas la seule à
vouloir combler ce vide
la russie est également prête à
sécuriser ses intérêts nous sommes
capables de satisfaire tous les besoins
de l'irak en matière d'armement
la russie veut faire concurrence aux
états unis en tant que principal
fournisseur d'armes à bagdad
de plus moscou est un acteur clé dans le
secteur pétrolier de l'irak
les compagnies russes y ont investi plus
de 10 milliards d'euros et les contacts
entre les deux pays ne cessent de
s'intensifier pour mieux comprendre
l'avenir de l'irak nous revenons vers
myriam benraad docteur en sciences
politiques de l'institut d'études
politiques de paris
comment peuvent désormais évoluer les
relations entre bagdad et washington
avec l'arrivée de joe biden au pouvoir
aux états unis alors je ne vois pas pour
ma part de grandes évolutions pour la
simple et bonne raison que joe biden a
été rappelons le quand même
un pro guerre il a été il a sauté
l'intervention américaine en irak de
2003 il a été aussi celui qui avait
proposé à une certaine époque rappelons
le de parts de partage et de diviser
l'irak
donc il a fait aussi un peu partie
finalement sept de ces apprentis
sorciers américain concernant l'irak on
voit que tous ces plans ont été un échec
total ont même fait plutôt le jeu des
ennemis premier des américains à savoir
notamment les djihadistes qui ont repris
à leur compte cette idée de partition
territoriale pour en faire une ambition
khalifa les on a vu évidemment
quels ont été les effets à la fois pour
les irakiens et les syriens c'est à dire
la descente dans la guerre civile et des
années de d'ultra violence qui n'ont pas
d'ailleurs pris fin donc byetone et dans
le sera dans une logique de retrait avec
tout comme l'ont été obama et rogue ya
aucune je pense
aucune différence de vue d'une
administration républicaine à
l'administration démocrate sur la
question je ne pense pas que les états
unis soit un partenaire de premier plan
des irakiens et les irakiens de ce point
de vue on plutôt tendre et intérêts
comme je les dis à se tourner déjà vers
de nouveaux partenaires parce qu'il n'y
a pas grand chose à mon avis attendre
des américains aujourd'hui
justement parlons de ses nouveaux
partenaires possibles le premier
ministre irakien et essaye d'en trouver
partout par exemple l'arabie saoudite et
l'irak rouvrent leurs frontières fermées
depuis une trentaine d'années pensez
vous qu al kadhim y réussira à réduire
la dépendance de l'irak des états unis
et de l'iran il ya cette volonté comme
je l'aï dit mais c'est pas d'ailleurs
seulement lui on a vu au cours des
dernières années j'ai parlé d'un certain
nombre de contrats passés avec des pays
comme la russie la chine au niveau des
grandes puissances au niveau régional il
ya un rapprochement c'est vrai avec
l'arabie saoudite après soyons très
clairs
l'arabie saoudite ce rapprochement et la
réouverture de la frontière c'est
exclusivement pour des intérêts
économiques qui sont biens qui sont
partagées bien bien compris de part et
d'autre
ça ne veut pas dire que l'arabie
saoudite et pour autant un allié de
premier plan les irakiens les irakiens
aussi une politique je dirais qu'ils
visent à attirer sur leur salle des
investisseurs venant d'autres parties du
monde à commencer par les européens mais
au delà des européens ils essaient aussi
de voir ce qu'ils peuvent faire avec
certains pays africains certains pays
même d'amérique latine enfin y'a quand
même des relations historiques que
qu'entretenait l'irak avec le reste du
monde qui essaie justement que le
premier ministre essaie de remettre à
niveau de raviver c'est dans l'intérêt
de l'irak et c'est aussi une question
souveraineté un paix doit être en mesure
de choisir avec qui il veut échanger
avec qui il veut passer un certain
nombre de partenariats et les états unis
encore une fois j'insiste sur cela les
etats-unis n'ont plus grand chose à
proposer aux irakiens en réalité
en dehors d'un partenariat militaire qui
est lui même contesté de l'intérieur et
qui ont la vue n'a pas permis finalement
de résoudre la question par exemple de
l'insurrection armée de l'état islamique
la question des milices chiites qui elle
même donc combattu les américains donc
c'est quand même très largement le fruit
de cette intervention militaire
américaine de 2003 encore aujourd'hui
donc on ne peut pas attendre comme je le
précisais des apprentis sorciers d'être
ce qui apporte le remède miracle à ce
pays merci beaucoup meriam bentrad pour
cette analyse je rappelle vous êtes
docteur en sciences politiques de
l'institut d'études politiques de paris
merci encore d'avoir participé à notre
émission
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]